Hãy nhóm Thách chiến Tau sân bay Gérard Ford đã tiến vào đến khu vực biển Caribbean ngày bị sảo thống em một.
Chưa thấy Mỹ đang tăng tóc chiến sĩ quân sử, nhằm kiểm soát các tuyến phận chuyển mặt tuy ở tây bản cầu.
Đây là lực hợp 2 quan hùng hậu nhất, Mỹ triển 2 từ khu vực trong nhiều năm, với gần 12 to chiến,
hàng nghi Minh Sĩ và các phía làm tiêm kích đi cùng.
Dởi chức Mỹ nhấn mạnh, mục tiêu chính là đối phỏ các mỗi đea sửa chuyển Coo Sa,
và ngăn họn đặc môn mặt tuy, chứ mới cảnh Washington đã tiến hàng khoảng 2,5 kộn kích tử tháng chiến.
Để cả một tiêu chống mặt tuy, giới phần tin nhận đệng, sửi nhận dịnh của tổ sân bay Gérard Ford của tạo sức đếp chiến lượng lên bên đi dưới là,
nơi quan hệ với Mỹ thích được kăng hàng.
Sống xong với chiến khai 2 quan Mỹ cũng mở giọng hồi luyện quân sửa, và nè mạm.
Những gì biết này khiến khu vực Caribbean và Mỹ là tình, đứng chức nhiều dùi gió về ăn nình,
khi các khu dài lông ngày hả năng xung độc lau thang,
nếu các hả nạn đặc môn quân sửa vượt khỏi phạm đi trong mặt tuy.